you said a few different things you said
you know what kova did to me is it made
me
question a few things one of them was
working remotely it's one of the things
you talked about right the other one was
you know this and this and that some of
the things that you know i was looking
at was number one we've been told you
know when i went and started working on
morgan stanley dean with a day before 9
11 even when i was in the army everybody
would say buy a roth ira and diversify
okay diversification
that's a concept we've heard for a long
time uh inflation increases gold
whenever there's inflation peter shift
oh my gosh gold's gonna go because you
know we printed 40
percent of the us dollar has been
printed last 18 months gold's gonna go
up we didn't see that cause and effect
you know we didn't see the cause and
effect with that taking place
uh you know what are your thoughts with
some of these things where the
traditional conventional way of things
have been questioned based on the last
18 24 months inflation and
you know inflation and diversification
are both bromides
there there are these uh
simplistic terms that people toss around
but no one really thinks very deeply
about them in my experience i mean let's
start with inflation
inflation is not two percent inflation
is not the cpi
it's not seven and a half percent
inflation uh properly understood is
simply the rate at which the price of
anything
appreciates in the currency which is the
frame of reference which means that you
can calculate an inflation rate for a
picasso painting which is different than
a building in new york which is
different than a bond which is different
than a market basket of of goods and
services that you wish to buy which is
different than the market basket of
goods and services i want to sell you
so what's the real inflation rate it's a
vector
right it's not a scalar a scalar is like
two percent no it's not it's like an
n-dimensional vector and there's a
different inflation rate for everything
in every place
for every time period dynamically
evolving right
once you understand that you realize
that
there's probably two inflation rates of
interest one inflation rate is the rate
at which uh cost of living is going up
for a middle-class family
that's not the cpi because the cpi is a
manipulated market basket
set by
a politician or a bureaucrat that's
that is uh
engineered not to go up in price very
fast
most average people would find that
their inflation rate is higher than the
cpi
and if you know for example we don't
include the cost of buying a home in the
cpi even though it stands to reason that
just about any reasonable person would
want to buy a house at some point in
their life
so you can calculate a consumer
inflation rate which is different than
cpi but you can also calculate an asset
inflation rate that's the rate of that's
the cost of getting rich or staying rich
if you want to be wealthy
it's not good enough to keep up with cpi
you have to actually keep up with the
rate at which assets are appreciating
right um
the cost of housing went up 18.8 percent
year over year this case schiller
according to case-shiller index right
that's another uh that's that's a common
asset
but if you look at
the s p index which is a market basket
of desirable companies that gives you a
surrogate for a monetary inflation rate
the monetary inflation rates been
running seven to ten percent a year in
the us at the same time that the cpi has
been running one percent
if you understood that you understand
that your cost of capital is more like
10 percent which meant that any
investment you made that didn't yield 10
was making you poorer you were losing
wealth you were you know any business
person understands that i couldn't get
you to accept a two percent roi on an
investment
so
if you if you understand inflation's a
vector
then then you start to realize that the
inflation rate in miami beach is
different than it is in kansas city
and you understand that the inflation
rate if you want to stay wealthy is much
higher the inflation rate in 2020 was
about 25 percent for assets
the inflation rate
for bonds was was at one point higher
right you could have bought a bond for a
million dollars that yielded fifty
thousand dollars in interest a decade
ago
if you wanted social security if you
wanted 50 000 in income risk-free the
rest of your life the cost was a million
dollars
when the 10-year yield went to 50 basis
points
you would have to pay 10 million dollars
for the same bond
the bond went up by a factor of 10.
what's the inflation rate
right the inflation rate in that
particular case was a hundred percent it
was like hyperinflation
you had hyperinflation in the bond
market
you had infl massive inflation in the
asset market you had no inflation in the
domino's pizza delivery you know netflix
market for a while
and and if what you want to do is live
in your parents basement and watch
netflix and order pizza
then the inflation rate
much much lower for you
and if you wanted to if you wanted to
stay wealthy or you wanted to get
wealthy or hold shareholder value
inflation rate looks more like 30 40
percent in like 18 months
so once you understand inflation is a
vector then you stop paying attention to
just one cherry picked number
because what you realize is i can
manufacture
any inflation rate you want simply by
adjusting the market basket of products
and services and
by definition
by definition if i never include assets
in the market basket of desirable goods
then you will always
ignore asset inflation which is the most
pernicious inflation
so we have had hyperinflation since 1971
but the inflation has manifested itself
in the assets
and the pr here's the pernicious thing
about it
i've literally brainwashed you into
thinking that asset inflation isn't a
bad thing it's a good thing and it isn't
inflation at all
it's actually investment gain right so
so that's
when
when i convince you that a bad thing is
a good thing
right we've we've come to a a bizarre
point so
we're living in inflation since we went
off the gold standard it's just in
manifesting the assets we have
hyperinflation right now it's just
manifesting itself in the assets more so
than in the goods and services
now if you go to diversification it's
another bromide another silliness you
should be diversified lots of people say
that a lot of times the people that say
that to you want you to give them your
money
right it's like i'm i'm a hedge fund
manager and so i'm going to stand up and
tell you you need a broadly diversified
portfolio of like international equities
and domestic equities and like some of
these commodities and it changes all the
time it's very complicated it's too
complicated for you to figure out so you
just give me your money i'm gonna charge
you a two percent fee keep 20 of the
upside and i'm going to invest it in
this hyper complicated array
diversification of
stuff
right
i'll give you a simple idea go buy
bitcoin don't give me anything i don't
want your money i don't want the two
percent i don't want 20 of the upside
and bitcoin is a diversified index
of the entire world economy and
certainly the crypto economy as it comes
to its senses
you can believe one thing or the other
thing
you can imagine if you're in the
business of managing people's money the
last thing you want to do is tell them
the answer is just buy this one thing
and hold it for a hundred years how do i
make money off of that
right
on the other hand what's the problem
with diversification
well uh first of all the problem with
diversification is diversification is
selling the winner to buy the losers
and the second problem with
diversification is
you're not really diversified at all
because everything you own is probably
correlated to one currency which is
collapsing so let's let's deal with them
one at a time
you own apple stock in the year 2010
a mutual fund manager or a hedge fund
manager would tell you he's going to
diversify you because when apple stock
doubles he's going to sell some of that
so he can buy some hp or some dell or
some other ibm or some other computer
company and when apple doubles again
he's going to sell some more to keep you
diversified in the computer sector
because he wouldn't want you out of too
much exposure to apple
the problem with that is that at one
point apple
became 150 percent of all the profit in
the entire mobile phone industry
that is to say the winner eats everybody
not only does it eat everybody
everyone competing against apple is
losing money to compete against apple
so you're selling the winner
to buy the losers you're going to sell
facebook to buy the newspapers you're
going to sell
google so that you can buy every every
company competing against google you're
going to sell amazon to buy the other
retailers amazon won
walmart almost kept up
15 000 retailers lost
right and why is that
well it should be pretty obvious why it
is right now
when you have a dominant digital
monopoly the digital monopoly eats
everything else and apple computer is
the most valuable company in the world
because apple computer is literally
the most valuable company in the world
they can ship a product to a billion
people over the weekend for a nickel and
their competitors can't
so selling the winner
to buy the loser
is an awful strategy
the only people that made money in the
stock market in the last decade were the
people that that owned fang they owned
apple amazon facebook google microsoft
there's no diversification here at all
so if you're if you're if you're
investing
in a stable currency
you have to keep in mind that digital
monopolies uh are dominant and they
crush everything else then and
everything else goes to zero so the only
everything else goes through zero name
another retailer you'd rather own than
amazon
so you're saying ethereum's going to go
to zero what i'm saying is that
ethereum's a different subject we can
talk about in a bit what i'm saying is
if you're a conventional investor
the winners tend to crush the losers by
far and so diversification of selling
the winner to buy the losers is not a
good idea
of you know eventually all yeah
what what portion of the s p return is
attributable to five companies out of
the 500.
it's like 80 or something ridiculous
like that right so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]